eh bien oui vous les voyez les bixi qui
sont de retour dans les rues de montréal
après dur hiver
la nouvelle saison des vélos en
libre-service commence officiellement
aujourd'hui et ce malgré les problèmes
financiers du propriétaire
mathieu didion la grisaille continue de
s'acharner sur bixi sa mise en service
pour la saison se fait sous la pluie est
seulement plus de 2000 de ses 5000 vélos
circulent dans les rues
on est un peu en retard cette année
compte tenu de la température
la société de vélo en libre-service qui
exploite bixi se trouve depuis janvier
sous la protection de la loi sur la
faillite
elle est accablé de poursuites et a
accumulé des dettes de près de 50
millions de dollars
malgré tout les fidèles demeurent les
abonnés sont aussi nombreux cette année
qu'à pareille date il ya un an
définitivement encourager davantage mais
c'est essentiel parce qu'un but aux
pratiques des stations avait partout
femmes en général ça marche pas abîmer
mais les commanditaires eux ne sont pas
au rendez vous comme en font foi les
panneaux sans publicité les mauvaises
finances ternissent l'image ça peut
attacher par contre la volonté des élus
de nous supporter
la mise en service des bixi survient la
veille de l'approbation par un tribunal
du transfert des actifs de la société de
vélo en libre service à la ville de
montréal son principal créancier le
volet international de la société
appartient depuis vendredi à un nouvel
acquéreur
et si matthew zions radio canada
montréal